[Music]
on this friday night protecting our most
vulnerable
from kovid 19. ottawa falls short on its
commitment to improve long-term care
homes
we need funding as calls grow for
governments to intervene
a first nations decades long crisis with
dirty water
i've never had access to clean drinking
water i'm 50 years old
how is the mess going to be fixed why
does it have to be like this
competing visions for the future of the
oil industry how the race for the white
house
could affect alberta and once in a
lifetime discovery the songbird that has
scientists so excited
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
kobit 19 cases are rising across the
country now and it seems lessons learned
from the first wave in the spring
have not led to meaningful change in
many long-term care homes
despite promises to protect the most
vulnerable outbreaks
are on the increase again in quebec 44
long-term care facilities have at least
one
active case of covid19 now ontario is
reporting
active outbreaks in 77 long-term care
homes
the problem is so concerning ontario's
independent commission into long-term
care felt compelled
to release some of its recommendations
early among them
not to delay fixing critical staffing
shortages it says a study on how to do
that was released in july and that
further study of the study is not
necessary
what is required is timely
implementation
as david aiken reports in our top story
tonight it's not happening fast enough
in quebec the government has deployed
what it described as
swat teams to four long-term care homes
where
coven 19 has come back that province is
determined
not to repeat the scenes from the spring
in a virus
that is so difficult to control
i think we've done a good job so far
canada's top
public health official says the
outbreaks are different in this wave
what we have seen is that the numbers of
long-term care facility outbreaks have
increased
including in quebec and in ontario
the size of the outbreaks are smaller
than in the initial
wave exactly a month ago in the throne
speech the trudeau government promised
to help the provinces
better protect those living in long-term
care facilities mostly by creating
new national standards for care so far
though
no legislation has been put before
parliament and developing national
standards has only come up in passing
on the bi-weekly calls the prime
minister has with the premiers
i think the first step and one of the
advantages of a federation like canada
is
we can learn from each other on how to
deal with
particular challenges premiers are
unanimous
that the one thing ottawa must do is
give them
more money for long-term health care no
problem at all sitting down
with the federal government and coming
up with a collaborative
plan but most of all we we need funding
meanwhile hospitals in ontario are
warning that elective surgeries may have
to be canceled
because hospitals are being used to help
manage the outbreak in long-term care
homes
two hundred thousand elective surgery
procedures were canceled in the spring
wave
and now hospitals are worried the same
may happen in the fall wave
donna all right david aiken in ottawa
thank you
we know the virus is spreading through
communities and in some places it's
moving too fast for contact tracers to
break the chain of transmission
that is deeply worrying manitoba which
has the highest number of active cases
per capita in canada reported
163 cases today 51 people are in the
hospital there with the virus and that's
a new record
too most vulnerable again are people in
long-term care homes
brittany greenslade reports from
winnipeg
it's home to manitoba's deadliest care
home outbreak and the struggles at
parkview place has doctors raising
red flags if i had parents there i'd be
concerned
the facility has 108 positive covert 19
cases including winnipeg's latest death
and the 15th at parkview place dr samir
sinha is the director of geriatrics at
mount sinai hospital in toronto
and says more needs to be done is this a
tragedy
absolutely were these deaths preventable
absolutely
were these deaths unavoidable absolutely
not
a march inspection of the care home
found major concerns with cleanliness
and infection control
and saturday's first in-person
inspection since
had health officials say there is an
immediate need for more training
on outbreak protocols we're reliving an
experience in winnipeg right now
parkview that we've seen repeatedly
played out
and frankly things that have taught us
what not to do
in ontario an ottawa long-term care home
faced a similar outbreak with comparable
numbers
more than 100 people linked to the west
end villa have tested positive for the
virus
and 15 residents have died the ottawa
hospital has since taken over patient
care
a move manitoba's health critic says
should happen here
at this point i think the government
needs to step in take over management
and make sure that residents
staff are safe and
receive the care and the resource that
they deserve but the province has no
plans to take over care at parkview
place
we don't have any any immediate plans
for you know for me to order
any any place to be taken over the
province says
instead it will work on the home's
staffing issues and providing
extra resources brittany greenslade
global news
winnipeg there is some news tonight
about vaccine research the federal
government is spending an additional 214
million dollars to support
made in canada vaccine research prime
minister justin trudeau warns he doesn't
anticipate a vaccine will be ready until
later next year at the earliest
canada has spent more than one billion
dollars to secure millions of doses of a
vaccine
if a safe and effective one is developed
and deals have been struck with
half a dozen pharmaceutical companies
the prime minister says canada is now
distributing hundreds of thousands of
abbott labs
rapid tests for covet 19 across the
country he says it's now up to the
provinces and territories to determine
how the tests will be used as part of
their testing strategies
the rapid tests can deliver results in
as little as 13 minutes
in quebec more than 900 new covid19
cases were reported today
and there's a warning the health care
system in the greater quebec city area
is on the brink of being overwhelmed the
region is under a partial lockdown
bars gyms and entertainment venues are
shot indoor and outdoor gatherings
outside of work settings are also
banned the province's deputy premier
says the situation is critical and she
had stern words for those
not obeying the rules today i want to be
extremely frank and crystal clear with
you
if we keep on the same track as we
currently
are going as we currently are we are
going straight
into a wall the health care system
will not even be able to take care of
you anymore
in some cases alberta's caseload
keeps rising too for the third day in a
row it set a record for daily new cases
432
more than 100 people are in the hospital
in alberta and four more people have
died from covid19 and
next door in b.c 223 new cases
were reported today in ontario another
toronto hospital has declared an
outbreak of covet 19.
sunnybrook hospital says five cases have
been identified in a surgical unit
all infected patients are asymptomatic
one has since been released
officials say the virus has not spread
to other units
at least six toronto hospitals are
dealing with covid
19 outbreaks promises are being made
again to fix the grim water problem that
has upended the lives of hundreds of
people in an ontario first nation
the nescanaga first nation is a remote
community about 430 kilometers northeast
of thunder bay
for 25 years now they've had to boil
their drinking water
and now the water has been completely
turned off because an oily substance was
found in the water supply
preliminary test results show high
levels of hydrocarbons
a compound that can pose a health risk
those who live there say it's shameful
this can happen
in canada mike lucatour reports
this is what we're asked to live like
this
in canada former chief of nuscanagar
first nation
was getting water the only way that's
safe in his community
earlier this month an oil sheen was
spotted in the water reservoir
the treatment plant had to shut down and
most members of the community were
airlifted to thunder bay
we're living in a country that's very
rich
why does it have to be like this i've
never had access to clean drinking water
i'm
50 years old chief chris muniz is
calling for a complete overhaul of the
water system saying the current
situation
can't continue young mothers go to the
lake
to scoop water from the lake
so they can bait their children so they
can ration the bottled water that are
that's being provided his community has
been under a boil water advisory for 25
years
now in 2015 the trudeau liberals
promised an end to all water advisories
on first nations territories
by march of 2021 the prime minister
points out progress has been made
but he wouldn't directly address the
issues at muskonega
it is difficult as we all know to end
these long-term boil water advisories
otherwise
other governments would have done it a
spokesperson for indigenous services
minister mark miller went a little
further saying efforts have been
redoubled
to help the community adding quote the
construction of the community's new
water treatment plant
is in its final stages upgrades to the
waste water plant
have been funded by isc and are
currently underway
local leadership is refusing to let
people back home
until the federal government meets some
basic demands including
making water available 24 hours a day
even if that means residents have to
boil it first
mike lacrouter global news ottawa
tension is growing near caledonia
ontario protesters are holding their
ground defying a judge's order
to permanently leave a construction site
that's at the center
of a land dispute
members of the six nations of the grand
river expanded their blockade yesterday
evening after an
injunction was issued violence broke out
police accused demonstrators of damaging
one of their vehicles
protesters say officers fired rubber
bullets
today demonstrators blocked the road to
the construction site with a bus
this is a red zone there's to be no
development here i don't think that's
very hard to understand
i'm not going to tolerate violence you
don't go after our police
you don't start burning telephone poles
you don't start digging up roads
that's unacceptable and we won't
tolerate
the dispute over a subdivision began in
late july demonstrators say the
construction is happening on unseated
indigenous land and
violates the first nations sovereignty a
group of major canadian publishers is
calling on the federal government to try
and force
google and facebook to pay their fair
share for news content
on their platforms the media industry is
facing big challenges right now
challenges made worse by the pandemic
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stephenson explains what the issue is
all about
news media canada which represents
canadian newspapers including the
toronto star
and the globe and mail say that they are
threatened by the dominance of the two
big tech
firms in the digital advertising market
a new report released
thursday lays out a number of
recommendations which would make
companies like
google or facebook pay for news content
on their platforms
the report calls on ottawa to consider
new regulations that would expand the
intellectual property rights
publishers can exercise over content and
allow them to band together in a
government-sanctioned
collective bargaining unit this is a
monopoly problem
and you know historically when markets
have been faced with
monopolies like this governments have
had to step in
and um and create a fair and equal
playing field google and facebook
control between 60
and 90 percent of the digital
advertising market which has become an
increasingly vital source of revenue for
the publishing industry
in a statement google says the claim
that google owes
hundreds of millions of dollars to the
news industry
is disappointingly unfounded the news
media canada report
misrepresents how the internet has
impacted news publishing
and fails to account for those who have
not managed to transform their business
to the digital world canadian publishers
have been fighting for compensation for
news content on social media sites for
years
the big u.s tech firms have strongly
opposed attempts in both australia and
france
to introduce similar policies mercedes
stephenson
global news ottawa late today facebook
responded saying this report
misrepresents the way that some of our
products work
news organizations in canada choose to
post their content on facebook to reach
prospective subscribers monetize their
content and sell more advertising
facebook says there are many ways to
approach these complex issues and we
want to work with
news publishers and the government on a
solution
a new way to vote in pennsylvania it is
proving popular coming up
we explain why there could be some
drawbacks
in 11 days the eyes of the world will be
on the u.s for the presidential election
millions of americans have already cast
their ballots in early voting and in
pennsylvania this is the first time
revamped laws allow voters to request a
mail-in ballot for any reason
there's been a surge in demand and as
mike armstrong explains
that could cause problems on election
night
pennsylvania has never voted for
president this way
it's called no excuse absentee voting
you request a ballot fill it out and
either send it in or as these people are
doing
drop it off in person there you go a
proud citizen
i love the early drop-off i think it's
the best thing that could have happened
to us i see it
i don't see it going away when the state
overhauled its early voting system last
year pre-pandemic it didn't know how
popular it would be
it also didn't know how complicated it
would end up being
pennsylvania had about 6 million votes
cast in the last election
this time around it's had close to 3
million requests
for early voting ballots election
officials are already warning there may
be problems when the counting starts
and urging patience obviously the closer
the race
the longer it will take to know who the
winner is
this part of the election is called
canvassing the ballots the first issue
is that under pennsylvania's new system
officials are only allowed to start
counting ballots november 3rd
once the polls closed even ballots that
arrived weeks ago
can't be counted in advance it's also a
slow process
some have suggested that it won't just
take days but it could be
weeks until the elections are certified
now that's just the counting add to it
the legal wrangling that's ramping up
this new system was brought in by the
democratic governor and republican
lawyers have been fighting for weeks
everything from poll locations to poll
observers to postmarks
pennsylvania will count ballots received
up to three days after the election
republicans wanted them rejected if they
arrived late that fight went all the way
to the u.s supreme court just this week
good to see you all there's a lot to be
gained by rejecting
early ballots because they're most
likely votes for joe biden
of the 2.9 million requests for early
ballots in pennsylvania
63 percent were from registered
democrats 1.8 million
registered republicans were less than
half as many only
700 000 the ballot is stacked in a pile
to be counted
last month the state election official
warned a hundred thousand votes could be
rejected over mistakes in how they're
sent in
in 2016 donald trump won pennsylvania by
just
44 000 votes rejected ballots could have
a
major impact on the results mike
armstrong global news
lancaster pennsylvania
still ahead the big buzz in washington
state over murder hornets
you're watching global national
[Music]
we're about to go into a dark winter a
dark winter
and he has no clear plan we're learning
to live with it we have no choice we
can't lock ourselves up in a basement
like
joe does well in case you missed it the
second
and final debate between the american
presidential candidates was more
dignified
than the first in part perhaps because
they knew their mics could be muted
donald trump and joe biden tackled a
range of topics including climate change
and the contrast between them on that
issue is stark
as eric sorenson reports what biden said
about the future of oil could have
implications on the outcome of the u.s
election
and on canada for donald trump
it was a rare opening to try to separate
joe biden from voters in oil country
would you close down the way i have a
transition from the oil industry yes
oh transition it is a big statement it
is a climate era reality check
texas alone has more than 350 000 jobs
in the oil sector
other states have fracking and trump
knows they are swing states with close
races
he is going to destroy the oil industry
will you remember that texas would you
remember that pennsylvania oklahoma vice
president it's sensitive
one oklahoma democratic congresswoman
tweeted here's one of the places biden
and i disagree
we must stand up for our oil and gas
industry
biden later offered reassurance we're
getting rid of the subsidies
for fossil fuels but we're not getting
rid of fossil fuels for a long time
climate change hasn't been the main
issue but a biden presidency could be a
defining moment says this academic
it's something that people need to hear
both in the united states
and in canada which is that we are going
to be making a transition away from
fossil fuels
watching closely canada's oil industry
alberta is spending millions
to construct the keystone xl pipeline it
would run from alberta to refineries on
the texas gulf coast
a presidential permit for the keystone
xl pipeline trump approved the keystone
permit three years ago
biden has pledged to cancel it alberta's
premier aims to change biden's mind if
he's elected president
we're going to point out should there be
a change of administration that
the united states needs a safe
secure reliable source of energy
will that work no i don't think so i
think the um
premier of alberta is uh
projecting what he would what he would
like to see
instead i think he should be listening
closely to what biden said
last night it was five years ago that
president obama first decided to block
construction of keystone xl who would
have thought the men in the background
might ultimately be the one who would
stop it once and for all
eric sorenson global news toronto
and because it's 2020 there's news
tonight about murder hornets officials
in washington state have found
the first nest of asian giant hornets in
the u.s
they found it in a tree on private
property in blaine washington that's
about 50 kilometers south of the bc
border
they'd been searching for it because a
few of the hornets were sited in the
area
a couple were tagged with radio trackers
and ended up in this nest it will be
destroyed and it's hoped their hornets
will be eradicated because
a group of 30 of them can decapitate
tens of thousands of bees in only a few
hours
hence the name murder hornet
next a rare non-binary bird in
pennsylvania
today at powder mill we caught a really
cool bird
researchers say finding this cool bird
is a bit like finding a unicorn it is
half male and half
female it's a rose breasted grow speak a
common species but
researchers at the nature reserve in
pennsylvania say its plumage reveals
something remarkable
it has colors of both a male and female
pink under its right wing which is the
male color and yellow
the female color under its left wing the
condition is known
as bilateral ganandromorphism
it's thought to stem from an error
during egg formation and it's extremely
rare in birds
and because it's friday let's keep going
with strange bird theme at a dutch zoo
an african penguin couple both of the
male stolen entire nest of eggs from
another penguin couple both of them
female
zookeepers say homosexuality is fairly
common in penguins and they often give
eggs to same-sex penguin couples that
show
signs of wanting a chick but the
penguins don't usually go ahead and
steal the eggs themselves and that is
global national for this friday i'm
donna friesen and that's it for the
birds
tonight's your canada is elbow falls in
bright creek alberta where the foothills
turn into the rockies
there are beautiful spots all over
canada please email yours to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching rob and gil will be
here over the weekend
and i will see you back here on monday
have a lovely weekend take care of
yourselves
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you